[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez déjà sauvé une
personne de la noyade
moi oui non c'est pas vrai non
ah bah voilà à a alors commencé passé
oui alors je n'aime pas raconter cette
histoire parce que ça fait je me la
raconte moi mal et la raconter j'étais
avec un ami on a dans une maison très
luxueuse un super mois à la piscine son
petit gamin de 3 ans y va dans l'eau
avec personne ne le remarque ce qui a
été dans l'eau direct où on était en
train de poser de serviettes et on se
retourne et alpes ticket sous l'eau lui
et son père qui regardent pas moi objets
love navès je jette mon portable je
plonge super beau gosse ouais je prends
le petit je le sors et je les embrasse
s'il me regarder son papa sam aussi j'ai
fait ça dans ma vie
av